now we're in an interesting time as we
record this because the writer strike is
going and so money let's talk about it
well wow you really lit up right oh my
God yeah oh people are fighting over
money and all kinds of stuff and so but
one of the uh things about the writer
strike is that there's this rule that um
and and we all want to do the right
thing that podcasts you know can't
promote certain projects but I am
allowed to talk about books that I love
that people have written and that's why
I wanted to talk to you because you've
written a book sure I'll join your cult
and which is a fantastic title sure I'll
join your cult by Maria Bamford and uh
you are adored you are a beloved uh
stand-up comic and you wrote a fantastic
book and I just wanted to say start off
by saying congratulations and to
everyone listening right now go get this
book it's fantastic and there's so much
to talk about here because your whole
career has been you are so open about
about what you've been through and man
you've been through a lot listen I like
to uh well monetize uh self uh real yeah
I I like telling everybody everything
and it turns out that's a cash cow uh so
so you going to say monetize your pain
well or just like you have you ever read
the book The Giving
Tree yeah yeah where um which I'm trying
to rewrite it as the giving condo uh but
all there was was the shade of the condo
you can lay in the shade you can't come
in because you sold it to Russia but um
uh uh The Giving Tree the premise is the
tree gives everything until finally all
there is is a stump for the little boy
to sit on who is now an old man and uh
yeah I have nothing left to give except
you know stories I do like I like open
book accounting that's one of my last
things I have to give I'm a
multi-millionaire I am uh worth $3.5
million in assets so that's multi and uh
you know so I feel like and and my dad
passed away which means uh he was a
physician uh I am white it was
generational wealth uh so I'm I'm doing
okay over here and I think the one thing
I have to give is full you know
open full disclosure yeah because I love
companies that do that chobana yogurt
where they to they taught everybody in
the company got to take accounting
classes and then find out what
everything in the uh yearly report means
uh so there's actually some way you can
argue for a raise or to go oh that's why
I'm paid that amount I'm listening yeah
yeah listen I go a different route than
chabani see I go more of a I don't know
what's say Vladimir Putin rout yeah it's
no one's
business uh how much wealth there is in
the walls of the Kremlin no Mysteries
Mysteries uh yeah if people ask any
questions they just go away yes yes
there's a lot of poison poison in the
muffins yeah oh by the way gorle have a
muffin wipe my door knobs before I use
them and I put that in the book like I
put in a a financial bit of like a
because I on that I find this stuff
fascinating and not because I know
anything like I'm I don't know anything
about money nor do I know if I'm doing
the right thing or the wrong thing uh
but it is such an emotional topic I find
it you know people get so mad or so
embarrassed or so ashamed including
myself like every time I see my
accountant I'm just
like doesn't matter what they're saying
you know oh you're in the same amount
how dare you like I it doesn't yeah it
it's the emotions uh don't match uh the
numerics it's interesting it it flips
can flip so quickly from the the the
flip between gratitude that you have
something and rage that you don't have
more of that thing is so instantaneous
and it's such a human thing yeah there's
somebody asking have have you ever been
asked to do something for free oh yeah
which sometimes you know if I think like
sometimes let's say and this is a
current uh shtick I'm working on but uh
Grimace who I I know Grimace uh is a it
doesn't even matter who the person is
but sometimes you get a text from a
famous person at around midnight uh on a
Saturday night who says you know in sort
of a business you up and and let's just
say it was Grimace which is the limal
space between the Hamburglar and mayor
MC cheese yeah I remember Grimace he was
love was he the he was the uh purple guy
purple but didn't he represent the
shakes the milk shakes well didn't they
just put out a Grimace Shake in
commemoration he's
having no he's definitely doing well
Grimace is finally having his moment
yeah and I love Grimace um but then uh
Grimace at hey do you want to work on
this thing tomorrow and wait a minute
Grimace the character from McDonald's
it's a placehold a placeholder for
someone I know Vladimir Putin oh I let
just say it's Vladimir you could have
just said someone I know why are we
talking about Grimace because it has to
have the weight and the celebrity and
the
authority and the fear involved anxiety
involved of meeting someone as powerful
as Grimace face to face in your own
living room yes like there's some sort
of like your knee shake a little bit you
and I basically and I also the minute
you said Grimace I know it's body you're
talking about but go ahead so I you know
I texted all my friends in dtor
Anonymous which is a 12st program which
is a lot like uh Tony Robbins if Tony
Robbins uh was a small uh it was about
49 and talk like this um anyways but uh
and I said you know what I really want
to get paid for this and uh so I asked I
asked grias for about 800 bucks and 300
bucks was to pay the venue that he
wanted to use in my neighborhood 100
bucks would be the tips for the bar EA
to keep it quiet uh 100 bucks for the
person who we were going to Commander
into doing uh something with us and then
300 bucks for myself because I have an
addiction to to clogs anyways this all
sounds by the way this all sounds very
reasonable reasonable yeah so now
Grimace who I
adore uh I think the way he paid out the
money was in hundreds in a very slow
fashion pass of aggressive yeah in a way
that suggested he did not have the money
and uh I know that's not true can't
possibly be true no Grimace I mean all
that money from the shakes and I mean
it's not Grimace but you know we yeah
Grim is on Cameo he's got to be billions
served right so I just yeah it's that
kind of thing where I think I need to
have empathy for grimas because
obviously they're hurt like they're hurt
by me asking for money like there's
something offensive in me asking for
money and then you know and also I'm it
it's just
interesting was it for a charitable
event no no oh okay that's so different
I do a lot of things uh and I don't want
to you know shoot my own horn but I give
and give and give um so many charitable
causes but that I get I understand sure
I'll show up and and and do the thing
and here is my argument with Charity
kicks I am often asked by a fan uh the
people they're trying to get money from
are not fans
uh they are very wealthy people in Napa
Valley or somewhere where I recently did
a benefit and bombed uh so hard uh
because people in Napa Valley they've
had some wine they don't want to hear
about schizophrenia research in my Chunk
on suicidal uh ideation they would like
to have uh how Mandel come up as soon as
possible um and that's why that's why I
refuse to do benefits cuz I I just I
just think it's I'm hurting people I got
to a point and there's no way around it
but tell me if you agree performing for
people who are
eating I that's just something that when
I hear chewing and I hear silverware and
gulping when I'm trying to tell a joke
that I sweat it over I I'm very unhappy
thanks a lot
gordley G's also eating a massive
cobbler right now with a big wooden
spoon yeah it feels sad and if there's I
mean I don't know if if some people are
enjoying themselves for me uh I feel
like it's like a a gig where it's like
combat Duty where I'm like taking a
bullet yeah are for somebody and so it's
like it's unnecessary and everybody's
suffering